Pro Football Hall of Famer Kurt Warner
how are you Kurt I'm doing good how are
you ready what do you think what's going
on we can what do you see I mean
obviously we all feel there's something
going on you know to what degree I don't
know if anybody really knows you know
watching in week one you know a lot of
people were talking about arm strength
and some of those things I saw him make
some throws from the backside hash to
outside the numbers on the other side of
the field some deep come back throws
which is one of the longest throws in
football with plenty of velocity so you
know I didn't get the indication that
you know there's something wrong with
his shoulder to the point where he can't
you throw it philosophy you can't put
push the ball down the field yet I did
see in week one we saw it again last
night is he misses a lot of layups you
know a lot of those throws that are just
by NFL standards wide open and he just
flat-out misses him
and you know for a number of years I
just feel like sometimes he doesn't have
the best technique he throws a lot with
his upper body throws a lot with his arm
and you know when you do that you have a
tendency to to kind of be up and down
and sporadic with your with your
accuracy and that's always been the case
with Cam he's been better at deeper
throws when he can really push the ball
down the field than the underneath rose
but you know I think to myself was a
left foot that he has an injury with I
don't know how much that really affects
you throw in the football it's not your
plant foot so it's really hard to
determine exactly why he's missing these
throws outside of just technique stuff I
don't feel like his armors hurt he
wouldn't be able to make some of the
throws that he has made he just got to
find a way to become more accurate if
they're gonna win some of these games
and he's going to put his team in best
position and then obviously at the end
of the game I mean it just it makes no
sense
outside of you know he's more injured
than somebody wants to let on but you
don't give him the ball in that
situation that you don't run the
quarterback power and you know get to
lead backs in there and get your big 250
pound quarterback in and run for a half
a yard you know to try a gimmick play
where it's more about fooling teams than
actually you know
out you know how muscle in them or
executing them for a first down just
makes absolutely no sense because that's
where km has always been at its best and
where they've always used him is in that
area of the field so there has to be
something going on there you know
whether it's something lingering or it's
just saying hey we don't want to get him
hurt because we need him but that just
made no sense to me last night well I
mean it's snowballing now we're showing
on the screen eight straight losses in
starts for camp eight straight now last
year there was his shoulder and you
point out some of the throws look you
know the the deep the deep throws deep
middles shows that he does have the arm
strength could it be between the temples
Curt did you ever have it between the
temples issue when it came to mechanics
and things like that
not so much mechanics but I mean yeah I
think that can always play into it you
know if you know if you're thinking
about your foot because it is bothering
you a little bit can that you know
affect the way you throw football the
way you follow through or the way you
plant of course it can when you're
coming off a shoulder injury I never
really had a shoulder injury but yeah I
mean you know those things can
definitely play into things when you're
playing as opposed to just look at what
the defense does and reacting off what
the defense does if you're thinking
about anything else they can affect you
in a lot of different ways so you know
it always been through over the last
couple years and maybe what he's dealing
with right now I think it's quite
possible that you know when you try to
be too perfect a lot of times is when
you you know are farther away from
perfection than when you just react and
play and we always say that as players
you want to get to the point where you
can just react you know that you know
what you're doing and you don't worry
about technique you don't worry about
any injuries you're just back there
going oh this what the defense does bank
throw the ball you don't think about
trying to make sure you set it in there
perfectly and that you hit the guy
between the numbers you're just good
enough that you react and you make those
throws so could it be that he's pressing
could it be that he's trying to be too
perfect with some of the other issues
that he's dealing with yeah that's all
possible and it gets in between your
ears like you said and it usually takes
you further in
further away from who you are as a
player and it really seems like that's
where cams at right now this isn't the
cam that we've come to know you know
whether it's reaction to just taking off
and running you know we're just getting
back there and ripping it and if he
misses one so what he comes back and
gets the next one he just doesn't seem
to be playing with that same type of
confidence right now Kurt Warner year on
the Rich Eisen show on the Curt and I
will be hanging out with mooch and her
for another edition of NFL gameday
morning 9:00 a.m. Eastern on Sunday
they're both in their fifth year they're
both in their options they're both
without long-term deals on the table I
give you Jameis or Mariota Curt I'm
going to go sports talk radio in here
you got to choose one which one do you
choose for the next five years
good question
Wow I'm probably taking Jameis because
I've seen more upside as a passer from
him than I have Marcus you know but we
continue to talk about it with Jameis is
that the bottom line with Jameis is he
makes a lot of plays on the football
field but he makes too many mistakes at
critical times he hasn't been able to
delineate between what is a good risk to
take and what's a bad risk to take and
you know we've seen those guys in the
past the great ones find figure that out
as they go and then they make the all
these plays and you ever make a mistake
here there but they make way more plays
than they make mistakes and then the
guys that are just average even though
they're talented are the guys that never
figure that out and they give you one
great performance and then the next
one's awful and another good performance
in the next one's awful and that's
really where he's been he's been a
roller coaster the entire time but I've
seen more from him passing wise than
with marques Marcus again has had
moments but his moments have been fewer
and further between then Jameis that I
really don't know because you know
Marcus will while you every once in a
while and you go cash there it is he
shows you that he can do everything but
it's just not there all the time from a
timing standpoint in a big play capacity
and really see in the field and you know
being able to build around him so
both very inconsistent so far in their
career but if I have to pick one I'm
probably picking Jameis hoping that
somehow someway we can we can get him to
to eliminate some of those you know
bigger risks that he's taken and come
back on the interceptions and I think if
he does that he's got a chance to win a
lot more games now that's game one of
week number two as soon as we're done
with game day morning taking everybody
up to kickoff of the bulk of week number
two you're gonna be taking off for New
Jersey you were the voice of along with
Kevin Harlan Monday Night Football on
Westwood One and what a dandy this is
going to be between the Browns and the
Jets I won't ask you if you've ever had
mono Kurt so we'll just put that one
aside you're it's interesting you're
gonna be in the building here Greg
Williams was accused by Odell yesterday
of having dirty tactics and said he'd
said he's his own teammates told him
that Greg Williams last year was
counseling his players to go low on
Odell and take him out of the game for a
preseason game you have been on the
business end of a Greg Williams defense
as a matter of fact but some of the
games that you were in one game in
particular was part of the bounty gate
testimony I wonder what you think of
Greg Williams saying he's never coached
those tactics Kurt I'm sure this will be
part of your Monday night broadcast we
might as well front-loaded here we go
well first of all rich I am taking next
Monday off so I will not be at that game
just to clarify that's one of a couple
that I'm taking off on you man okay so
that I'm glad I'm getting the exclusive
than here curtly I got no problem so I
just wanted to clear that up but yeah I
mean I have been and it's interesting
because I kind of feel like when you're
answering some of these glare when Greg
is answering some of these questions
it's really about semantics and you know
I don't want to say that any coach ever
coaches cheap shots you know coaches you
know go out and hurt somebody for the
long term take out a knee so they can't
play the rest of the year but I do
believe for you know outside of Greg
Williams for a long time that there's
been lots of teams that take the
approach hey let's knock this guy out of
the game and you know it's
in the malicious manner it's not in the
you know we're gonna take a cheap shot
and try to knock him out it's simply we
don't want him to play against us so
let's go and hit him really hard let's
hit him really often and let's try to
get him you know to the point where you
know he shuts down or you know again
injury or you bang him up enough that
he's sitting on the sidelines and set a
plane against you that's been a part of
football for a long long time and so you
know when people ask Greg that stuff you
know I think that's the semantics of it
I mean obviously there's there's
evidence that you know he's he's done
things to say hey let's knock this guy
out of the game let's go after this guy
now whether he coaches the cheap shot
portion of it I don't know and that
could be what he was references you know
I never tell anybody to go out and blow
somebody's knee out or do anything like
that you know but but obviously very
interesting you know with all that's
come out and knowing what the past of
Greg Williams has been you know because
I look back to my situation and
obviously I got knocked out of a game
against the Saints in that kind of
bounty gate time period but the hit on
me was 100% legal you know the guy hit
me between the numbers I didn't hit my
head he didn't go low yeah I was in kind
of a defenseless position but that's
part of football sometimes you know I'm
trying to you know cover up and make a
tackle on an interception and I got
blown up and so you know I look at that
and you know all I can do is say hey it
was a big hit it was a good hit and it
was a clean hit and if things happen
like that it's it's part of the game
that I chose to play you know but I
think it's gonna be fascinating to see
how this plays out and there's more
questions on both sides especially you
know aimed at Greg Williams because of
because of his past well next time I ask
you that question I'll give you the
oxygen tank for the high road okay I
don't want you to get lightheaded Kurt
okay
before I let you go let's talk about
your protege that's dominating here at
USC and his first couple of
opportunities ketone Slava so you
coached at Scottsdale Desert Mountain
High Curt fascinated enough he's he's
doing very well with an opportunity that
was afforded him through injury which I
find amazing that you it's kind of a
Kurt Warner birth here for him in USA
huh yeah I mean uh you know how you said
fascinated that I knew he had a great
spring and they were very high on him
and I obviously played it as the number
two you know going into the season and
then the injury to JT and you get
elevated and pushed into that position
but I mean I'm so excited for Caden that
he is a young man and obviously I've
known for a while but yeah a kid had
always wanted to be great he always
wanted to learn he wanted me to push the
envelope with him we asked him to do a
whole bunch here in high school and a
big part of that was I knew he wanted to
play the next level and he had skills to
play at the next level and so you know
every week I was trying to push the
envelope with him and trying to teach
him new things and see how far he could
go at the high school level in hopes of
preparing him for an opportunity just
like this and you know and I love what
they did with him this past week you
know watch the tape and talk to him a
little bit and a lot of the stuff that
you know that they called for him this
past week was very similar to stuff that
we had done in high school and I don't
know if that was a conscious effort or
if that was just part of their offense
but you saw the results of it he looked
extremely comfortable he knew what it
was doing with the football played you
know very mature you know I loved him
you know getting the guys fired up
coming out of a tunnel before the game
and just showing his leadership so you
know I think we're always surprised when
somebody has this success this quickly
whatever level that is but I'm not
surprised that this young man was going
to have success at this level because
he's prepared for it and he's been
pushed for it and he's he's worked hard
you know every different thing that he's
trying to do so he can play at this
level and have this kind of success so
can't wait to see where it goes I mean
you know I mean coming in as a true
freshman
USC and starting the way that he did if
he continues to play well the sky's the
limit for what he can accomplish and
what he can be and probably the
opportunities at the next level and so
I'm pulling for them we can't wait to
watch it play again curtsies Sunday CFC
long ways see this weekend thanks to the
call brother all right man you're the
best that's Kurt Warner for more of the
Rich Eisen show tune - audience Channel
239 on DirecTV for free on BR Live or
download the Rich Eisen show app